hello there I'm John Oliver host of last
week tonight it is January the 3rd and
we are still on hiatus but I wanted to
take this opportunity to wish you all a
Happy New Year
which is something you can still do for
another day or two before people start
to think you just came out of a
week-long blackout also I would like to
talk to you about New Year's resolutions
at the exact middle ground between lying
to yourself and lying to other people
every December for some reason we decide
that next year will be the one when
everything turns around and we'll quit
drinking or finally learn how to
pronounce the name of these berries ah
ugh is it a chi a a K at a say sign
there's no way to know for sure the
science simply isn't in yet but but
let's be honest we're a few days into
the new year now and if you haven't
broken your resolutions yet
statistically you are about to and that
can be depressing but don't panic all
hope is not lost because the key thing
with resolutions is not how to keep them
it's how to revise them once you've
failed
let me explain let me explain the main
problem with New Year's resolutions is
that we set our expectations way too
high for instance lots of people say
they want to exercise more but that's
hard exercise is like reading for your
muscles except you can't watch a movie
of someone else exercising and basically
get the gist of it so so instead of
beating yourself up because you haven't
gone to the gym yet simply lower your
standards for what counts as exercise to
anything that brings your heart rate up
that way instead of jogging simply try
waking up late for work or taking a
pregnancy test that way you haven't
failed to keep your new year's
resolution you've just succeeded in a
different way oh well let's say you
bought a crock-pot
and promised yourself you'd use it to
make yourself nutritious meals clearly
that was never going to happen
so simply revise your promise to saying
that you would use it period
that way if you find mice in your
apartment you will fulfil your
resolutions simply by filling the crock
pot with water
get to low and making those mice a
kick-ass hot tub yes those mics are
gonna get so much tail so much tail I
stand by that joke I stand by the tail
junk I do not apologize
and finally if scaling down your
resolutions doesn't work how about
scaling them up to a completely
unachievable level for example resolve
to throw out the first pitch at Yankee
Stadium on July the 4th or win an Igor
which means that winning an Emmy Grammy
Oscar and the Kentucky Derby that's hard
you're not going to do any of those
things which is what you won't feel bad
when they don't happen because deep down
we all know the key to a successful
resolution is not hard work and
dedication it's managing disappointment
and that's it
and speaking of managing disappointment
we will be back on HBO On February 14th
until then please enjoy your failures
goodbye